welcome to this video may tomboy so or
something what's his name Carlos boy
Sonny okay ready I'm winning this pawn
now probably I'm not winning this pawn
but it starts I don't know said really a
good way to play it doesn't seem so easy
to get it back end I know this feels a
bit awkward for white or not maybe you
can go t5
I don't know I think do you fire the
whole almost has to do that ok Knight f6
Knight c3 e6 oops that's a very weird
position 95 well
so if i take here what is he doing night
f7 maybe ah hmm this is also not bad but
do have something better this move looks
wrong
95 doesn't really convince yeah let's do
that yeah spent too much time you're
trying to refute this stuff they have to
get rid of that part details I go pee
should be six or 221 bishops exits check
that will be compensation his position
is so we're uncoordinated that giving
away the Hornets not a big deal so 95 95
or some other move yeah that's probably
okay so he's got Bishop f4 so I would
like to keep the knight on d5 so that
Bishop f4 is not so easily playable
doesn't have a great square I think yeah
some nights for this 95 mmm yeah I can
take here and go look the tool may be
also not so bad to have have the bishops
yeah I love maybe equinox on something I
can probably keep the balance somehow
returning a corn or so but just to be
careful 94 maybe 94 and 95 and trading
stuff mm-hmm doesn't want to
okay I can take care take age who it's
not bad 94 is really irritating here
okay going from simple simple moves Roxy
five I guess we should be three and the
equal material at least I've got the a
porn Wow taking that that's surprising
am I not just keeping this now and have
pressure on the poem and maybe it's got
Bishop t5 move like that
yeah I can take Ruby 295 hmm yeah maybe
not your life so yeah you can take d5
cheeky too I can take with the rook of
course hmm you told still hangs me or
can I go for some kind of self pin as
helping I'm I mean roop the area can I
can I pin him somehow
okay I'm not very happy with this but I
really couldn't seem something much
better that's really not greater time
mourning dove 3 is rubbish so let's go
back hmm that wasn't good you can
probably invade invade on the 7th rank
95 maybe hmm sorry voices and my voice
is failing me yeah this is this is a
problem night eh force is a threat and
this is mate I don't want to lose this
game but I think I will yeah I shoot
black resigns hmm it's disappointing
this is a pretty good position here for
compensation but I couldn't really
didn't play it well yeah this should be
ok really maybe maybe some sub there
somewhere around here I can improve
can I cross the to keep it simple method
maybe this is wrong this is probably
wrong yeah after 95 I'm not in after
Bishop t5 I don't have a great move this
is the comp move and it is better right
yeah this is better I'm keeping those
pieces under control and see 5 NB 3 or
some kind of candid cancelling each
other out I'm losing this so i have to
be careful this is given by the combat
don't quite get it well here this is
keep kept protected and you'll just give
zero after cheeks rope shakes Shaggy and
something like that I really I really
couldn't find a good move him I mean
what I did was terrible probably losing
but yeah I'm in trouble that is given by
the computer but ok I'd find something
but difficult check and this is what the
engine points and it's of course strong
now if he wants to avoid the rook trade
after the trade there's very little
material left so I probably get a
drawdown and if he tries to keep them
all I have far more chances now route 88
yeah no I'm threatening some kind of
perpetual if white white is also not
doubling on the sample this is
much much better yeah this was losing
basically yeah now I'm lost yeah I
cannot do anything against Rupert e7 I
mean this what kind of move is that I
can do this for example now I played
badly bad game I mean not the game the
begin again was kind of okay but here
this this is this is wrong I have to go
Knight f6 after Bishop t5 I really don't
have a good move now it just it just
isn't any good just isn't any good what
I wonders that that opening was strange
swati he goes there see you 45 yeah
engine gives be five but that's a tough
move to play and and here yeah computer
wants to do this which yeah I saw that
but I wasn't sure about this is the line
and then I've thoughts at Higgs and I
wasn't sure this is really great or not
or what yeah it's not bad the ship is
pretty good on g7 and I'm active yeah
till I couldn't really bring myself to
play that okay thanks for watching